I love the Apollo Theater it is an
amazing place I never played here before
never been here before
such an amazing theater with such a rich
amazing history well yeah and there's
also that that cool spooky legend about
the theatre I don't know your what are
you talking about what you don't know
about the legend of the Phantom of the
Apollo phantom of the Apollo no who's
that
[Music]
oh these are the bottom of the Apollo
Theater wait a minute wait a minute look
a lot you look a lot like jb smooth you
just got a lot
striking resemblance to JB smooth I'm
not baby smooth I'm the Phantom of the
Apollo Theater why are you I hear
phantom because this is my theater and
you need to get though something no stop
doing that now shouldn't you you're like
a phantom of the city you shouldn't you
be singing all of this right now
hell no The Phantom of the Opera sees
the Phantom of the Apollo tells jokes
[Applause]
check this out
is that your hair I was suicide note
from your barber
[Laughter]
when Apollo first opens it had a no
black policy as the coding changed it to
or no last policy hey this show was free
right
where y'all overpaid and all those
freckles on your face you look like
someone use a Swiffer to clean up some
co done though to worry and you haven't
forgotten about you
uh hi phantom he looks like a baby on
HGH
[Music]
come out here just to insult us is that
the only reason you're here yes angel
plump baby smoothes new movie almost
Christmas
[Applause]
Lucy Payne
you